16 years that's how long angela merkel
the still incumbent chancellor of
germany was in power and of course she's
leaving some kind of legacy not only in
germany but across the world and we want
to find out with our panelists today
great panel by the way
what exactly that legacy is and to
discuss that today
we have three panelists and the first
one from south africa the south african
foreign minister from there and the lady
pandora is with us today and she says
the medical era will be remembered for
its very positive german impact on
global progress thank you very much for
being with us today
also with us today from india gorgit
singh former indian ambassador to many
places
including
germany and he says mackel was not
india's but china's best friend in
europe so you can see there's a lot to
discuss right there thank you for being
with us today
and finally
from greece we have janis farofakis
member of the greek parliament and of
course former greek finance minister
with us and he says medical's policies
condemned germany to secular decline and
the european union to stagnation
and i would say let's get this show on
the road let's get started with mr
varufakis mr vargo focus you once said i
believe it was one in one of our
podcasts by deutsche welle you said that
angela merkel was a good manager but
that she's not a leader what exactly did
you mean with that
no i actually didn't say she was not the
leader said that she didn't have a
vision
she was a manager of a crisis at hand
and a magnificent one at that
and moreover let me qualify the
statement which i truly made that you
mentioned uh but it's not complete uh
she is leaving the chancellory
of the federal republic
much stronger
than she inherited it
but there is a paradox there
germany is much richer than she was
15 16 years ago the chancellor is much
much more powerful and yet
the surpluses the economic surpluses
that have amassed in the country
have been purchased universal commerce
at the cost of secular stagnation of
very low levels of investment that are
jeopardizing the future of germany and
and and that is massively important a
fragmenting stagnating european union
just let me jump into there mr viral
focus because can you be a leader
without a vision
yes absolutely
uh she you know
there are two ways of leading a company
a football team um you know a nation um
you can be a fantastic firefighter you
can
be excellent at
keeping the balance the equilibrium
between the different factions in your
government in the european union and so
on and that's where she excelled
but
the period during which she presided
over the european union's affairs not
just germans
it was a
moment in history that future historians
would look at as the opportunity for
europe to become a federal republic to
move towards proper integration a
political union
and merkel did everything in her power
to prevent that from happening
in the context of keeping the
equilibrium within her cabinet within
the european council going
um i would like to get a different
perspective on this if you don't mind
and i would like to hand it over to
minister pandor here because obviously
you have the perspective from africa do
you perceive angela merkel or did you
perceive angela michael as well as a
leader without a vision
well i certainly don't i don't agree
with that
i think she gave shape
to european politics
in a manner that no other leader i think
in europe has done in the past two
decades
i i'm surprised that uh mr varufaki's uh
fighters opinions because i thought that
she was one of the leaders who certainly
tried to make an attempt
to
cogently address the crisis that
confronted
the people of greece several years ago
and i thought she'd been one of those
leaders who'd been interested in
identifying a european solution which
some of us as social democrats
felt was a very harsh solution by europe
but she certainly was was part of that
but i don't perceive her by any means as
a weak leader
or a leader without vision i think there
are times where
her boldness certainly shone through
when
addressing matters particularly of
refugees and migration into europe
including not being afraid
uh to engage other leaders in europe to
be more empathetic than they were
minister pandora i would like to get to
those uh to the migration crisis maybe
later because i just want to avoid
getting too much in the europe corner
here because uh your perspective from
africa is so valuable on this so let me
be more precise with the question do you
feel like angela mackle had a vision
for the african continent
well certainly from the perspective of
south africa and
various countries on the african
continent i think the
compact with africa which she has played
a really strong role in
has been an important initiative and the
realization that what we need to get
into africa is foreign direct investment
to address core issues of development so
from an african perspective i think she
has played a positive role we've been
able um
to engage with her on on a range of
issues including
more recently the responses to the
pandemic there are areas where she does
not agree with us
and the positions we've taken up and
being angela merkel she's able to state
those objections strongly and we are
able to respond in kind
ambassador singh um
you're uh you're you have the indian
perspective obviously
um do you feel like angela merkel had a
vision for for that area it's very
complex obviously if you look at the
geopolitics of it but maybe as an
example uh before we get into economics
because i think that's something that
our african viewers can also relate to
do you feel like
she was that humanitarian leader when it
came to the corona crisis that that
beacon on a hill that many thought she
was the leader of the free world
you know the corona crisis i think uh
numbed some of her legacy
to me chancellor merkel is the icon of
globalization of a resurgent germany
after the you know unification and uh
you know the putting the g20 together so
these were the kind of things i
associate her name with but when you
mention global crisis like for the
pandemic i think there they clamped down
and they became very nationalistic uh
and therefore the globalization of which
she was the icon
came to a bit of a halt but i think that
is part of merkel's legacy merkel being
a scientist was very good at having a
practical approach to policy unhinged by
ideology so once she took a position she
had no problem in taking a u-turn on it
sometimes then carry the whole weight
with her so i think that was the
adeptness of merkel she had good ideas
which she mentioned you know like
climate change the climate chancellor
not much change in germany so i think
good ideas not always implemented but i
think always in the interest of germany
unhinged by ideology i mean i think
that's something we need to discuss with
mr valuefaq is that a good thing or is
that a bad thing unhinged by ideology
well look uh i
happen to be one of those people who
believe that ideology is everywhere
the most ideological practices are those
who are practiced in the name of not
being ideological so let's not get stuck
into this
angel america was certainly pragmatic
and yes she did make u-turns the way she
changed her
attitude to nuclear energy uh
she she was perfectly capable of
changing course
but
from the very beginning of the euro
crisis in particular
she made
a horrific choice a choice that was
terrible for germany terrible for the
rest of europe what am i talking about
in early 2009 the german banks and the
french banks uh went bankrupt as a
result of the lehmann's brother debacle
beginning in wall street
and from that moment onwards uh
following the advice of her advisors i'm
not even blaming her personally she
covered up she concealed that bankruptcy
by means of huge bailouts of the bankers
and she did that in exchange for
at the price of
um
very large-scale austerity in germany
not just in greece and then she exported
that to germany very viciously and i
beg to differ on this
by creating a desert and calling it
peace you don't really
win a peace prize
uh the situation now in the in in europe
is perfect stagnation whereas in germany
you've got the lowest level of
investment since the second world war in
relation to the amount of liquidity that
there is this is the legacy she's
leaving behind yes but she was very very
present
if i may chime in here she also made a
lot of money available for uh countries
not in the eu during the pandemic
and and if you look at the numbers for
example 64 of germans are still happy
with medical she has the highest
approval rating of all worldwide leaders
according to a gallup poll and in i
believe 29 countries how do you explain
all that if she made these horrible
mistakes
well
look i am not a black or white person uh
i believe it's shades of grey i
personally like angela merkel i have no
objection to her as a person i think
she's very liable very agreeable when
she let in a million syrians i applaud
it i said i made a public statement as
in a political opponent of her saying
that i feel very proud to be european
because of angela merkel the problem was
that two weeks later she reversed that
and she went into bed proverbially
metaphorically with president erdogan of
turkey striking awful agreement that
created prison camps in the greek
islands and effectively created a
fortress europe so she was this kind of
contradictory personality uh
the
i have no doubt that she had the best of
intentions for africans for asians for
nigerians for
afghanis and so on but the policy that
she ended up practicing in the end in
order to keep the equilibrium within the
german system was such that you have the
lowest level of investment especially in
the green transition the lowest level of
good quality jobs being created the
highest level of inequality that's all
as a result of the fact that she was
simply trying to keep
business as usual when business should
never have been kept as usual
we can of course not um leave this
discussion without talking about the
fact that we have the most
arguably the most powerful woman
worldwide in politics now leaving the
world stage
minister pandora what does that mean to
you
well i think that uh the fact that she
assumed that position uh is in itself a
legacy and held it up very very well
of course every leader would make
mistakes and no leader will satisfy
everyone i think if you do you're a very
bad leader
but for young girls and women young
women worldwide she has shown that it is
possible to lead one of the most
powerful countries in the world
successfully and even be of leading
influence in a powerful block uh such as
the european union i don't think we can
undermine her achievements or the
reality that there is a legacy uh
certainly there may be a and are
mistakes
i believe for example with the namibian
reparations question much more could
have been done
uh there could have been an earlier a
focused attention to key uh development
challenges on the continent
but from the perspective of south africa
we've had excellent relations and very
good development partnerships germany is
an important trade partner for our
country
and there has been very close
uh link between
germany and and south africa at the
political as well as the economic levels
so for women when talking to people
about angela merkel that's that's
something you hear a lot minister is
that a lot more could have been done and
ambassador singh um your initial
statement where you said that she was
the best friend of china china's best
friend kind of hints in that direction
was she blind to what china is doing
could she have done much more when it
comes to human rights for example in
china what's your position on that
well actually i was referring to that
she could have done more for india like
she did for china but let me say this
merkel had a very strong legacy in
developing the indo-german relationship
in 2011 her government set up the
indo-german commission
and that has done wonderful work at the
summit level over years
and i think she has put in a lot of new
things like climate green infrastructure
through the oda route into india
where she failed i think was in bringing
german business to india german business
kept nudging her to china
but she could never make them look at
india as seriously as they looked at
china as in the end i think the german
business was leading her china policy
and i believe she could have done more
for india but certainly even now
president ping calls her that before you
go please tell europe that i am not
really your rival and i'm ready to win
so she is china's best friend during her
presidency of the european union on the
very second last day
the eu actually signed up on a
comprehensive agreement on investment
with china and all my friends in germany
i spoke to lamented that that agreement
would actually happen with india so
between china and india in asia merkel
did a lot for developing the
relationship in india but the priority
remained china
let me um let me rephrase maybe the
question because i think you all agree
that angela merkel had this image over
the years i think time magazine maybe i
might be wrong said that she was now the
leader of the free world when donald
trump was the u.s president right and um
so she many people abroad associated
human rights with her liberal democracy
and um but when it comes to china and
back to you ambassador singh did she
fulfill that promise or not
i think she actually lost track of that
i mean they
ignored it
and that is why there is a crack between
europe and the rest of us because we
think that germany and europe often pick
these issues with countries they want
but are not consistent in picking the
issues with everybody so there's a lack
of consistency on this
um lack of consistency minister pandor
you are full of praise for for angela
merkel but did you see a lack of
consistency when it came to german
policies towards south africa as well
are you entirely
happy well there there are aspects as i
said that are of concern uh firstly the
whole matter of reparations in fact it's
not just germany's europe itself
in fact many european countries
boycotted our recent commemoration of
the
durban declaration on racism and other
intolerances at the u.n where we had a
roundtable so that just illustrates the
attitude of some leaders toward the
issue of black people
and racism
in the in the global community but i
think uh
leaders have to represent their
countries as well and i understand that
uh fully
but i i think there were times where she
went against even the german grain
um you know i am a fan because there are
very few women
uh who would uh are leaders of her
stature and who would stand up on many
uh
very issues that impact on the world
community and speaking from the south
african perspective in africa as well
she's been part of defining a new
strategy between the european union and
the african union and this is a very
important strategy and as i said she has
encouraged foreign direct investment
into africa for key
development initiatives on the continent
and many african countries are
benefiting from the work in the g20
compact uh with africa from the
perspective of south africa she has
supported the training of young people
in technical and artisanal skills an
area that we need a great deal of
training for young people in
so um thank you minister for that
because we don't have a whole lot of
time left i i need to get in there
because there's a of course one topic we
still need to discuss and it sort of
resonates with what you just said going
against the german grain may be even or
going against the grain of the european
union mr balofakis were you surprised at
what
angela marco did during the migration
crisis in 2015.
i was very pleasantly surprised
when she let the syrians in
and as i said before i applauded and i
i felt moved by her humanitarianism but
unfortunately only lasted two weeks when
they said they would the christian
democratic party started
boiling over with anger at her she
immediately reversed course and she went
from
wonderful humanitarianism to
a kind of
cynical misanthropy the agreement with
turkey
effectively meant
that the european union
under basis america's guidance was
sending billions of euros to the
president of turkey as a bribe so that
he would allow us europeans
to violate international law regarding
refugees effectively to deny refugees
their right
to uh
seek asylum in europe uh
you know the maurya
prison camp in lesbos is forever going
to haunt mrs merkel's legacy and that
comes you know this is why i'm saying
this is of course not officially called
a prison camp at a but a refugee camp
but yes understood what you mean no i'm
sorry
it was a prison camp you have not been
there i have been there it was a prison
camp and now it's even more of a prison
camp now in on other islands too there
are huge wars
you know somebody from nigeria somebody
from ghana somebody from afghanistan
they try to seek asylum and they're
imprisoned this is a prison camp we are
building within europe as part of a
policy that clashes
remarkably and awfully with merkel's
two-week
dose of extreme humanitarianism is for
which you know i will love her forever
right and is that is that um i'm sure
she'd be happy to hear that is she um is
that the defining moment of her
chancellory if you had to sum it up in a
couple of quick words mr [ __ ] and
i'll put the same question to all our
other panelists too
what is the defining moment of her
legacy
february 2009
she's told that the german banks have
gone kaput
and she gives them a huge bailout of 406
billion
euros without getting rid of the bankers
effectively practicing socialism for the
bankers and austerity for the rest of
europe that erect our chance of a
genuine democratic political union in
the european union
and ambassador singh what is the
defining moment
briefly
for you in angela merkel's 16 years in
office
you know when you talk about the refugee
crisis
you know in some people's life there's
an aha moment this was an oops moment
so i was not impressed by but what i was
impressed with was the
support and backing she gave to the g20
now i and the greek minister look at it
differently because we are not a
neighbor of germany we are not in the eu
we are looking at it from outside like
minister pandora is so i think the g20
has been something great for
all of us and i think merkel played a
very important role in that
thank you very much ambassador same
question to you minister pandor in those
16 years what was the defining moment of
angela merkel for you
i would agree with ambassador singh on
the g20 but i think we can't pull her
down
on the decision to
accept refugees into germany when
everybody was pushing back
there are many leaders in europe who did
not support her
there are many leaders in europe who
have been anti-migrants
and who have acted without respect for
human rights i don't think you could
classify angela merkel as the same as
those leaders
thank you very much minister um so i
want to thank all our
panelists for being with us today i look
back at 16 years of course uh 20 minutes
aren't nearly enough to discuss it but i
think we we got an idea of what you
think about angela merkel and i have a
feeling that even mr valuefakis will
miss her in a in a certain way if i may
say so